so this whole idea of ratio division
it's with intervals and it's about
slicing up intervals so that it's like 2
to 1 or 5 to 4 or whatever okay but
we're going to go to um an extension of
this idea literally okay
to illustrate it draw with me a line now
what we're going to do here so I should
say an interval um what we're going to
do here is not about developing a
formula or deriving a formula so I don't
feel an attachment to have any like an
actual Cartesian plane an x1 y1 x2 we've
already established all of that so now I
just want to get at the idea of if
you've got an interval in what ways can
you divide it okay so if I said okay
let's divide this into this interval
into three equal parts three equal parts
and if I place if I label some of these
points like so then that is a three
equal parts I could say that there's
this intervals PB right here I can say
that a divides P V now there are three
equal portions and I've said P to be
which means I'm starting from the left
and going to the right okay so what
ratio is it it's two to one isn't it
it's
now a divides P B in the ratio 2:1 um
but I'm going to add in a little detail
on this because you see where it's going
uh it doesn't just divide P B in the
research you want it divides it
internally in the ratio two to one
because a is on the inside of P B that
makes sense how else can you divide it
but I want to get this word in right
so a divides P be internally in the
ratio two to one okay
maybe you want to make a note I just I
just I'm trying to make a Beatty out of
this because so many students get
confused to matter that PB means start
here and here right not just
alphabetical all the time you really
gotta pay attention to the way they give
it to you okay but in the same way if we
just copy this diagram again same set of
points same set of ratios
okay um I've used PB is my interval
right but if not the only interval on
there right in fact there's at least two
others so I could say for instance
instead of a dividing up this interval I
could talk about P dividing this until
now that's a bit weird it's a little bit
weird but let me show you how it works
right
P divides a B now unlike a with respect
to P be with you got P with the tractor
ATP's on the outside peas on the outside
so it's not dividing internally it's
dividing externally that's a kind of
strange idea right right like if you had
a pizza you said hey divide this up and
you're like I'm going to cut over here
on a different table that's weird
okay but it's getting the same idea that
look this still division of intervals
okay it's just no one in our way now
remember I said that PB means start P
and end it big right so it's the same
thing here you start at a and then you
end at B now how would this work how
would this work answer if I start at a
right I have to go outside this way to
get to P and then I have to go the
opposite direction to get to be okay now
have a look at these two arrows that
I've just drawn right what ratio are
those two arrows to each other yeah
okay now I can think this in a couple
ways if I just think about them as
lengths just think about them as liens
then this is two portions right and this
is three portions so it is two three
okay so I can say divide a be externally
in the ratio two to three okay but as
you've noticed right and this is why I
put arrows on here these are going in
different directions they're going in
different directions not just that but
if you said okay let's have some
quantity and be his ratio right popping
your K in your L and so on
if you gain that a go and just crunch
this into your formula P would end up in
here wouldn't it right in fact two to
three inside there means you've got
divided this up into one two three four
five components in there right and then
now it's going to recover and then what
would happen is that's my one um two two
three
means you got to first and then you go
three so that's where P would be we
don't want it to be there right
so therefore to account for this and use
the same formula right there's one of
two ways to do it
um you can think all right I'm going
outside first my outside so I'm gonna
call this negative two going away from
be okay and then I'm going to go plus
three they just opposite directions
that's all okay so that's one way to
think about it that's the way that I
prefer personally um but
you can do this from two different
angles I'm gonna draw one more copy of
the interval and like you do the same
but same key hey B mmm
if I'm saying I've got a on brush start
at a I've got to go out here to paint an
endo over here to be right there's
nothing stopping me thinking about these
in terms are well let's just call this
one forward would which will make the
other one backwards okay because they're
in opposite directions
now that might we do relatively because
we don't me a little bit when I first
discovered it because ratio division of
all of the formulas is the one where
it's like order really matters don't
just like swap things around you'll get
something different okay
and the thing is we haven't swapped any
numbers this is a 3 & a negative 2 that
wouldn't work okay we swap the signs now
to satisfy you that this actually works
here's what this means okay
um when you are when you see the word
externally okay what that's telling is
one of these numbers is going to be
negative and it actually doesn't matter
which ones which okay